foreign
stores to Enterprise systems one of the
most critical Cloud skills is knowing
how to deploy a dynamic web application
but with the number of cloud products
and Frameworks expanding it can feel
overwhelming to learn how to deploy your
app in the cloud luckily there's a
jumpstart solution that lets you deploy
a Django web app on Google cloud in
minutes to lower the learning curve and
get you going
Django is a powerful open source python
web framework to build flexible
well-structured applications with lots
of modern features out of the box but
implementing a web app is more than just
choosing a framework you need a
strategic architecture that provides
scalable web servers serves Dynamic data
from a database and static assets from
storage and you can't forget about
security you need to encrypt sensitive
configurations and data and enforce a
model of least privilege between
Services you choose a cloud serverless
platform to handle the scaling for you
but that still leaves you having to
decide on and set up database and
storage options based on the
characteristics of your application
identify configurations and data that
are sensitive and choose how you will
store these secrets and finally you need
to make sure that all of these separate
components are configured and integrated
sure you can set up a cloud environment
yourself including compute a database
server web server CI CD security and
networking but you want to spend your
time working on your application and not
the underlying infrastructure there are
ways to ease the burden of creating
resources in the cloud like using
infrastructure as code tools but we want
to help you stay focused on what you
care about the development of your
application for your users
Google cloud has a jumpstart solution
where you can deploy one of the most
popular Dynamic web application Stacks
in the cloud in just a few steps and in
minutes
you'll Walk Away Learning how a Django
Dynamic web app can run on Google Cloud
you'll see how Google Cloud products
work together to run a sample app using
Google Cloud serverless container
platform manage database service secret
management CI CD tooling and cloud
storage
you'll also get learning resources for
updating the deployed application and
monitoring your application during
runtime
this jumpstart solution lets you deploy
a Django web app and all of its
supporting infrastructure
it's a sample Ecommerce product website
you have a storefront with information
about products plus the products
testimonials
you can attempt to purchase a product
and get notified it's not a real store
then a transaction with the timestamp is
recorded to the backend database
once the solution is deployed the
architecture includes the following
components
the web client is hosted on Firebase
hosting which is a complete platform for
web apps that is automatically backed by
a speedy Global CDN with https out of
the box the web client calls a Django
rest framework API backend written in
Python that's running as a cloud run
service in Cloud run is the manage
compute platform that lets you run
containers to handle incoming requests
the configuration and other secrets for
the python application are stored in
secret manager and secret manager is a
Secure Storage platform for managing
things like API Keys passwords
certificates and other sensitive data
static assets are stored in cloud
storage which is object storage
Cloud SQL for postgres is used as a
relational database backend for the
python application the jumpstart
solution lets you deploy the solution
with all the resources required once you
hit deploy Google Cloud will
automatically create and configure all
the cloud resources needed to run this
app and deploy the application code
once it's deployed you can access the
web app like a user and click on
products
or you can access it like an
administrator and explore the deployment
which consists of multiple primary
services that have been integrated into
a single Google Cloud project
then you can use our learning resources
and interactive tutorials to explore how
the application is built
for those of you who want to customize
the solution or automate the
provisioning and management of the
solution check out the solution guide in
more detail to explore the solution
backend check out an interactive
tutorial that lets you explore a client
server application to learn more about
your solution deployment
or check out the solution guide which
also walks through how to explore the
back end how to access your service
database static assets configuration
storage and how to update your
application to learn how to update a
client server application on cloud run
and Firebase hosting check out the
interactive tutorial to understand more
about your solution deployment during
runtime
and finally to troubleshoot common
errors check out the solution guide
now keep in mind this jumpstart Django
solution gives you a great way to
explore the capabilities of Google Cloud
but it isn't intended to be used as is
for production environments instead you
can learn a way to deploy Dynamic web
apps on Google Cloud using products that
are modular secure and scalable check
out the links below to try this
jumpstart Solution on your own
[Music]